HASHTAG WARS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
WELL, AFTER YOU WATCHED
"SHERLOCK" LAST NIGHT I AM SURE
YOU CHECKED OUT THE NEW SEASON
OF "KEEPING UP WITH THE
KARDASHANS".
(LAUGHTER)
SHERLOCK IS TOO SMART.
I NEED SOME BRAIN SORBET.
IN HONOR OF THE WORLD'S
WORST REALITY SHOW TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG IS WORSE REALITY SHOWS.
EXAMPLES OF--
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
YES.
GOOD.
OH, IT IS ABOUT TIME.
WHY I DON'T CARE WHO I TAKE
DOWN.
EXAMPLES OF THIS MIGHT BE
AMERICAN MIDOL, THE
NAP-PRENTICE, SEWAGE WARS, THOSE
ARE EXAMPLES OF WORSE REALITY
SHOWS, YOU CAN PLAY ALONG WITH
US AT THE @MIDNIGHT TWITTER
ACCOUNT.
READY, 60 SECONDS AND GO.
YES, AL MADRIGAL.
>> KEEPING UP WITH THE
SANTORUMS.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS!
YES, ROB HUEBEL.
>> FINDING BIGFOOT'S BALL SACK.
>> Chris: IF YOU FIND THE
BALL SACK, YOU FIND THE BIGFOOT,
I FOLLOW THE TRAIN OF LOGIC.
POINTS.
YES, ARDEN.
>> TODDLERS AND THE TIJUANA
DONKEY SHOW.
>> Chris: THAT WOULD BE A
REALLY BAD REALITY SHOW.
POINTS!
YES, ARDEN?
>> SO YOU THINK YOU CAN
DIAPER MICKEY ROURKE?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: YOU THINK YOU CAN BUT
YOU CAN'T, THE WHOLE SEASON.
>> WE CAN'T, HE'S TOO FAST.
>> Chris: POINTS.
YES, ROB HUEBEL.
>> CUPCAKE WHORES.
>> Chris: OH, I AM ONE OF THOSE,
MY FRIEND.
I AM WAY ONE OF THOSE.
POINTS.
YES, ARDEN?
>> THE BIGGEST LUGER, IT'S ABOUT
A REALLY FAT BOBSLEDDER.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: GOD, THAT IS
BRILLIANT.
POINTS!
I LOVE IT.
YES, AL.
>> DANCE UNCLES.
(LAUGHTER)
CREEPY, IT'S A CREEPY SHOW.
>> Chris: DEFINITELY POINTS.
ARDEN?
>> OH, AH, AH, AH, AH.
>> Chris: OH, NO.
>> THE AMAZING RACIST.
IT'S A STORY OF--
IT'S MADONNA'S WORLD TOUR.
>> Chris: YES, WELL DONE.
POINTS.
THAT IS THE END OF HASHTAG WARS!